[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute gibt was italiener oder sehr gut
heute gehts was italienisches und zwar
machen die homestake oder pasta pizza
jola das essen wir immer gerne bei
unserem lieblings italiener und man muss
dazu sagen das macht wirklich jeder
anders das ist ein rumpsteak mit nach
richtig leckeren tomatensoße und nudeln
wir nehmen da immer gerne tag der total
er teile das geld spricht man nicht habe
ich schon gelernt von meinen zuschauern
und es ist ein leibgericht ja am
günstigsten ist eigentlich nein aber es
ist wirklich super lecker so wird sich
vor allem auch und auch zu hause ganz
einfach zu machen
es gibt ganz viele variationen davon
also das macht wirklich jeder italiener
wahrscheinlich anders wir es uns am
liebsten beim entscheid oberhausen genau
aber bitte bitte nicht hingehen da ist
sowieso voll dann kriegen wir nämlich
kein tisch merken tolle werbung für ihn
so gemacht und ja ich hin
wir sind eigentlich der beste bei uns in
der umgebung aber bitte gebt mich dem
geht woanders stehen immer voll
zufrieden
kein platz mehr ok ja also er macht am
besten ich hoffe dass ich jetzt genauso
gut hinbekommen und ich dass italien
aber sein ich zeige euch jetzt aber erst
einmal die zutaten die er dafür benötigt
die stehen nämlich schon mal da für die
tomatensoße brauchen zwei esslöffel
olivenöl eine zwiebel 2 knoblauchzehen
zwei esslöffel tomatenmark eine dose
tomaten das sind 400 gramm einen
esslöffel getrockneten oregano ich habe
ich ein bisschen chili 50 gramm oliven
ich nehme die grünen zwei esslöffel
kapern
neben tabellenführer und für steak
brauche ich zwei esslöffel butter
schmalz hier habe ich zwei steaks und
500 gramm nudeln ich nehm tagliatelle es
geht im prinzip ganz einfach ich habe
schon mal die zwiebel und knoblauchzehe
geschält und jetzt kann ich sie noch
fein schneiden
das ist übrigens morath der kleine ali
das ist der bruder vom großen namen
charlie
er macht alles schäbig und fein
das war ja knoblauch jetzt city belegt
ein unterschied ob man den knoblauch
erpresst oder schneidet beim pressen
wenn sie dann noch hörte wie bei der
geburt beim knupfer fressens problem
wenn du sie länger stehen lässt dass ihr
dann eine bitterstoffe entwickelt aber
wenn es gleich weiter verwendet dann
passiert nichts
nokia selbst pressen
damit gleich alles gleichzeitig fertig
wird also sowohl das sonst als auch
nudeln und tomatensoße müsst ihr
natürlich eine bestimmte reihenfolge
einhalten
ich werde das rumpsteak jetzt zuerst zu
bereiten ich werde nämlich in der eisen
pfanne anbraten und dann im ofen weiter
garen lassen
und da braucht man etwa 15 minuten und
die zeit kann ich dann für die
tomatensoße nehmen also jetzt
butterschmalz in einer pfanne erhitzen
bei hoher hitze kann ich aber auch schon
parallel mit der sauce anfang und
staates olivenöl in einem separaten topf
erwärmen
jetzt kann ich hier schon mal die
zwiebeln und den knoblauch würfel
anbraten und zwar bei mittel hoher hitze
und wenn ihr kein induktionsherd habt
dann könnt ihr jetzt auch schon mal das
nudelwasser aufsetzen wenn es bei euch
extrem lange dauert soll butterschmalz
zurzeit und das fleisch habe ich auch
vorher aus dem kühlschrank genommen
damit es nicht mehr so kalt ist noch ein
bisschen kühl aber nicht kalt das liegt
jetzt in die eisen fahne und brass von
beiden seiten ganz scharf an
[Musik]
ums fleisch kümmere ich mich gleich das
komme gleich im backofen jetzt kann ich
erst noch die tomatensoße zu bereiten
dh die zwiebeln da kommt jetzt noch
tomatenmark dazu kurz mit anbraten dann
mit den tomaten aus der dose ablöschen
und hier könnt ihr auch gern noch eine
prise zucker reingeben das versteck
nämlich den tomaten geschmack und nimmt
auch so ein bisschen die säure und dann
kann ich jetzt noch oregano und chili
dazu geben die kapern und die sardellen
filets und dann müsste einfach aufpassen
dass ihr doch nicht so viel salz
funktioniert denn die sardellen sind
wirklich sehr salzig aber die passen
hier einfach wirklich super dazu also
die müsste auf jeden fall mit rein geben
und die oliven dich schneide ich jetzt
gleich erst noch und kann die soße dann
im prinzip nur mit salz und pfeffer
würzen mit gesagt abschmecken und die
darf jetzt so etwa 10 minuten köcheln
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt und
nehmen das rindfleisch das lege ich
jetzt nämlich hier im backofen gleich
auf mein backblech so bekommt von oben
und unten die perfekte wärme und ich
kann es dann bei 90 grad etwa 10 bis 15
minuten garen
je nachdem ob ihr es gerne medium möchte
oder lieber durch ich arbeite nämlich
auch gleich noch mit dem fleisch
thermometer das heißt wir gehen jetzt an
den backofen kommt das fleisch hier traf
schlägt den teller auch gleich darunter
der fleischsaft schön abtropfen kann das
nächste mal die temperatur
und ich jetzt gerne auf etwa 56 grad so
ist es nicht für uns wirklich ideal
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt
auch gleich noch um die nudeln
abzukochen und dann haben wir im prinzip
schon alles sehr
[Musik]
die tomatensoße küchen schon vor sich
hin und dies ist ein bisschen fest das
heißt ich kann jetzt hier bei bedarf
einfach ein bisschen nudelwasser
übergeben und ohne nudeln und zu flüssig
darfst jetzt auch nicht sein denn wir
vermischen später die nudeln dann direkt
mit der sauce perfekt es sieht schon mal
viel besser aus und im rudel wasser ist
ja auch ein bisschen stärke dabei das
heißt es bindet die soße auch und in der
soße die sardellen filets die verkochen
jetzt auch und es ist wirklich toll denn
dann verteilt sich das komplette aroma
in der ganzen soße und im prinzip bin
ich schon fertig die nudeln werden dann
nämlich mit der tomatensauce
zusammengemischt ich kann jetzt hier
schon sauber machen und dann wird die
strecken
[Musik]
die station jetzt auch fertig zumindest
das etwas kleinere das andere habe ich
noch im backofen die werdet es noch
gesalzen und gepfeffert und dann
schneide ich sie auch an es geht es auch
richtig schläge ja wahnsinn perfekt
perfekt
ja du magst du gar nicht zu arg medium
nämlich zu machen es ist richtig dass es
gibt so viele verschiedene nennt sich
das jetzt pink oder so keine ahnung ich
mir gefällt's einfachen modellfall thema
welches schon eine große portion oder
ihm durch diese gabe diese riesen gab
[Musik]
als die gruppe habe aber ist nicht
schlimmer oder sie damit ihr ehrliches
sagen ja also ich hab noch nie kohle
gegessen wo ich das schon geschnitten
bekommen habe ich will muss fertiges weg
bekommt ja ich wollte jetzt nicht so
viel geht es um fleisch ja ja ja das
sagt doch nichts zum sparen hier ist das
fertige homestake zone also
normalerweise ich möchte das noch kurz
erwähnen
murat ist so ein ganzer tag alleine wenn
es nach mir geht es nur ein halbes
deswegen ich hab jetzt auch mal zwei
gemacht aber nudeln für vier personen
da ist wieder was ganz ablöst war ich
hab noch nie gegessen wo die suche war
über das fleisch krüger nein dies mit
den nudeln w das war bis jetzt immer in
restaurants sowie über das fleisch
geworden
erst hier waren wir ja einen wert über
aufwärmung dann warten wenn es so sein
muss bei manchester klar ich hab gerade
für mich gekocht und sagt einfach gut
ich glaube das nächste mal koche ich
nicht mehr versetzt doch schon machen
können über min 2 ich will super gut
geld da spielt super und selbst noch mal
zu mir und ich mag es so wie es beim
institut so machte der enzo und so macht
jetzt die sally noch ein fleischstück
für die fotos und für die jungs hier am
set
ich glaube dir schmeckt gut gespielt zum
nachmachen empfohlen
ich glaube auch hier schlug mir dass wir
gut springen er sticht mich doch
geschmeckt mit nicht gut aber ich habe
mich enzo ja ein gescheites weg schon
bald zum ende und das essen wir jetzt
hier fertig also wir finden es richtig
gut und falls er das rezept gerne auch
noch machen möchte dann schaut aufs eis
- blog.de vorbei da steht noch mal alles
ganz genau wie pizza oder auch gerne mit
viel soße es dann bereitet am besten
gleich die doppelte menge an songs dazu
ist ja auch gleichzeitig eine pizza soße
und dann habt ihr ganz vielen sonst eher
fürs fleisch übrig ich finde übrigens
einfach schöner wenn man das fleisch
schon an schneidet man halt feiner aus
doch nicht so ein großer klub wir haben
spieler die sich gleich stoff ganz
sicher da will ich ja auch immer 500
gramm fleisch erst mal 100 gramm ich
bleib ich mag es am besten mit nico
lokal also macht bis zum nächsten mal
schmeckt gerne ich nicht gut aber es war
nicht überwinden terra zurück
[Musik]